it's called Xi Jinping vote on socialism
with Chinese characteristics for a new
era but you might have heard of it as
she thought it's the ideology that's
being promoted by the Chinese leader and
the Communist Party first mentioned in a
speech she gave after coming to power in
2013 it was officially enshrined in the
party's constitution in 2018 or only two
other leaders matadong and Dong Sao Ping
had their doctrines written into the
Constitution before that so what is it C
says its Marxism adapted from modern
China a framework which combines rule of
law morality National Security and
Global Leadership and elevates above all
the Communist party with she at its
Center the goal to quote build a modern
socialist country and Advance the great
Rejuvenation of the Chinese nation in
other words to make China Great again
but this campaign is more than just
trendy merchandise it's being spread in
websites books curriculum social media
apps and at one point there was even a
television game show
[Music]
it also features in China's diplomacy
what the government wants is for every
Chinese citizen to buy into the vision
that she has set out to build one of
efficiency development and strength but
also increasingly control over every
aspect of life and the silencing of
descent at all costs Xi Jinping sees the
breakup of the former Soviet Union as a
cautionary tale he believes they simply
forgot about the importance of a
unifying story and vision and he's
determined to make sure that China
learns from that lesson
[Applause]